[Music]
start by saying how much I love your
show and how thankful I am to Jeff for
uncle Jeff for saving it JP write a big
THANK YOU to Jeff thank you Jeff Thank
You Jonathan yes really sincerely thank
you so there I have so many questions
but listen you guys have wrapped on
filming the next season I know you have
your media points you've been trained
what are you what are you actually
allowed to say about nothing that's why
I'm sitting here to keep you in check
right I actually like legitimately I
don't want to know specifics but no sir
so I'm a fan I want to say it actually
happens no I want to know you know you
got to be able to tease it a little bit
like does it what can you tease the
Rings have opened up there's an imminent
Gold Rush and what that does to the
balance of power in the system in the
macro sense is completely change the
entire chessboard and all this tension
starts to build and the macro and in the
personal sense everywhere and it just
changes everything and some of us live
[Laughter]
you also see all of the characters go
through very different transitions and
journeys that we've never ever seen
before so that's all quite fresh and
exciting there's a lot of new characters
that come in and then kind of change our
characters journeys in a way that again
we've never seen before everyone plays
into it so it's not the same thing as
what we've had for the past three
seasons there's a bit of that in there
but it's also something quite fresh and
exciting so and it is it is a tonal
shift I mean if you're a fan of the
books you know that book four has a very
different kind of feel to it and the
show reflects that it has a frontier
kind of vibe what I will say is that you
get to see the team working as a team
like you've never seen them before
the Rocinante crew and and also I mean
all of all of the the characters have
come into their own and have started to
own their space and and if we had
encountered the kind of stuff that we
have to deal with in season four
in season one or season two we probably
wouldn't have made it through but
because of the all the experiences that
we've had over the past three seasons we
were able to deal with what were
confronted with like we wouldn't have
been able to is there any difference in
was there any difference making the show
under the Amazon umbrella versus making
it over at Syfy the production itself
was very similar you know even when we
were in limbo there for a minute
our crew waited for us you know almost
for over a month so we kept continuity
with the entire production team and
Alcon entertainment group who produces
the show and pays for the production has
always remained really supportive I
think we're the the difference is is in
the formatting we don't have to hit 45
minutes every single episode we have
more leeway to do and show stuff than we
have before
and and the reach and support on the
publicity side and distribution side is
very very different and and appreciated
and they Amazon really understands this
show and and it's pushing it out there
in a way that really reflects the
passion that we have and I will say that
the enthusiasm in the energy because
we've all been together the cast the
crew with the original crew has been
with us for five or six years so the the
ups and downs and the things that we
went through this season coming on there
was a certain excitement that I that it
felt like our first season in a lot of
ways and so in us being thankful to have
this opportunity to be able to tell this
story that we all loved so much and that
we all rooted for so hard and the fact
that we all come together and do this I
think there was a certain there's a
certain chemistry that's definitely
palpable and that you will see that as
you watch season four I want to get you
involved in this a little bit I'll ask
you how much listen there's gonna be the
fourth season but how much is it like
it's sort of not a reboot but it's a
restart at a new network it's a you know
at Amazon is there any sort of at the
beginning of season four sort of like I
don't want to say catch-up but some sort
of thing that allows like someone to
just jump in on season four or do you
recommend
they start at the beginning I think we
were talking before and we feel like you
could start at season four I personally
would probably start at season one just
to get a bit a bit of backstory but it
really does shift season four and it
would be understandable to b2b to just
start at season 4 without having to do
it but what's at all
oh no I agree at all you should
definitely start on season 1 100% of
yourself the justice right I have what
we call since I know you can't do
spoilers and I don't want you to ruin
anything what we call a few fun
questions and let's see how this goes
who ruins the most takes ha not me not
me look at that we have kind of an
absurdly prepared group we really do
like we we've literally rehearsed every
single episode from the first season of
the first episode on our weekends on our
days off you know who used to do that a
big group on ds9 Star Trek ds9
it's very weird that you do that as
another I don't want to say sci-fi show
but but the guys who played in the
Frankie's really they used to all get
together on the weekends and practice a
bunch of stuff work in the gang I would
I would say that we are a really
prepared much but we do also have a lot
of fun I mean you know we've been in fun
comes from being prepared so we do we do
joke around with each other on set and
have a good time with it but when it's
time we all we're in the zone and we
bring our a-game who is paying all of
you guys five dollars to cover up that
they mess up every day I see I don't
like to call it messing up I like to
call it I like to call it organic
evolution and growth and authentic
representation in the moment that's sure
I think that would be fair yeah $5 right
there who is the one that always gets it
in one is that dead serious I don't do
it all the time but I can Stephen
Stephens a bit of a one or two
how actually this is not one of the fun
questions I'm actually this is genuinely
curious how many of the 10 scripts you
guys are doing 10 episodes how many of
the 10 scripts did you have before
starting to film episode 1 they don't
give us no rain doesn't like to give us
scripts that he isn't he doesn't feel
like totally done or at least mostly
done so we just get the first two - us
too far in advance he likes us - yeah he
just likes us to focus on what we're
doing at that time and and so we get a
block at a time so two episodes I'm for
all for all of you do you guys how do
you and I'm gonna try to be brief since
I'm gonna run out of time but how do you
typically like to learn your lines do
you have like a thing is it hard for you
to remember lines I'm just curious about
everyone I've been acting asking this of
everyone recently what's your like pract
what's your thing for learning lines I
actually don't like to learn mile I will
learn them but I also like to leave them
a little unknown because I like to leave
room for what I'm gonna get back and
sometimes I feel like if I know him that
well I'm gonna be set into what the
scene is before I'm in front of the
other person so I as the season goes on
I get quicker at picking it off I can
just read it a few times and I'm like
okay I've got that
and then I'll try and like leave a
little room for like just seeing what
happens just in terms of the technical
kind of memorizing lines I might I do it
editorially so like I will read it out
to myself out loud over and over and
over again I know people in the I've
known a lot of actors who write it out
and that works for them it doesn't work
for me I have to hear it
so I hear it and hear it and hear it and
after a few times I got it in my head
I'll read it a few times I just really
like to know like what the intention of
Bobby is and then usually once they
understand like what she's trying to
achieve in the scene I'll just learn the
actual words over and over and then get
on see it and have a good play see how
and in one take yes I have like once
I've done the work and it's time just to
kind of get the words down
have a for whatever reason the best way
for me to get the lines in my head is I
have to walk and talk and so I usually I
I usually drag him along or my poor wife
and and so basically like they've seen
us walking around the neighborhood many
many more in my neighborhood many many
times because I need to walk and and and
just and listen and talk because I find
that if I'm walking and I'm you're
seeing people drive by seeing people
walk by is people looking at you like
you're weirdo and you're not getting
locked in anything but the listening and
going back and forth there's something
about that that occupying this is the
conscious mind with walking and doing
something else that the words just seep
in and oh my god how freaky but your
neighbors must be so freaked up being
like holy moly that's Amos
that's not ways you guys didn't love
seeing couple times usually when I get
on break and I see him coming at me I'm
like running away cuz he's gonna grab me
we're gonna be walking like a mile and a
half around the studio on my break I'm
like oh man
but I mean Wes kind of shared that I'm
it was very interesting actually you
guys are auditory and she's kind of like
insert and we're physical I have to
physically act it out like I I get most
comfortable when I'm on the set and I'm
actually blocking everything out and I
know which thoughts are coming when and
I get it physically into my body and
that's when when they lock in so that's
unfortunate for for some of the actors
I'm working with unfortunately I loved
all these answers actually um every time
for most promotions when you get a new
season
you get like a new soundstage or a new
set like that's the kind of thing so was
there a new sound stage this year or a
new set that you were super excited to
work on well we we is the first season
we really shot extensively outside and
there is there was this beautiful set
that was built in this quarry outside of
Toronto and that was an amazing
experience for us it was a new
experience for us as a production or new
terror or whatever and all of this will
make sense at some point this season
like I think it has to do with the
exploration of where you're going indeed
yeah
um I guess before I ran out of time do
you I don't obviously there's no I don't
want to do any spoilers I want to
reiterate that one more time but do you
feel that it God willing you guys are
gonna get another year but sort of like
how does it like without getting into
any spoilers does the finale leave it
you know how do you sort of our fans
gonna I just like actually have to
remember what the finale was Alexis it's
still no it's still in the nature or
gonna kill me
we always on right there I feel like
good writing does both it's all good
do you know what I mean like it's like
oh it could do this or and we have great
writers listen I need you to have
another season so I will petition Jeff
whatever I need to do you know what I
mean but there's eight novels written
all right that's my boys will be nine so
if we're following the path of the
novels then there's probably some
material left to be discovered listen
the greatest thing is that Jeff's a
sci-fi guy and that's me and my biggest
thing is does Jeff watch the show
because I heard he has at least five
dollars to spend on television and if he
does our Amazon team has been absolutely
sorry I got to wrap up with you so
Maddie Amazon but it was actually that
I'm out of time and if she is gonna kill
me listen I love you guys's show I
cannot wait to see it in December I
believe it's December 13 and yeah and I
can't wait to have scene and then talk
again thank you so much for coming by